대출 이자를 감당하지 못해서 매입했던
거 금액보다 더 좀 저렴하게 급매로
매각하는 계약도 좀
[음악]
있었고요네 안녕하세요 사나입니다
상반기가 이번에 끝났는데 작년
상반기와 비교해서 거래량이 좀 얼마나
늘어났고 어떤 지역에 건물이 팔렸고
어떤 분들이 매입했는지 bsn 계약한
거 기준으로 오늘 좀 영상을 찍어
보도록 하겠습니다 우선 작년
상반기보다 거래량이 한 40% 정도
늘어났습니다 계약한게 한 40% 정도
늘어났고 그리고 이제 거래된 지역
중에는 강남구가 한 50% 정도
거래가 되었고 강남구 내에서 대치동
노현동 삼성동 역삼동 신사동 청당동
순으로 이제 청
청당 청당 그리고 이제 마포구가
거래량이 좀 많았고 마포구 내에서도
연남동 계약이 좀 많았던 거 같습니다
서초구는 뭐 성동구 그다음에 중구
영동포구 강서구
동작구 서대문구 광진구 이렇게
해가지고 되게 고루고루네 계약이
체결되었고 그리고 이제 주로 매입한
연령층이 일단 20대가 10%
그다음에 30대가 25% 40대가
35% 50대가 20% 그다음에 6
70대가 한 10% 정도 됐습니다
제일 많은 연령층이 한 40대지만 2
30대 비율이 높아요 최연소로 사신
분들은 이제 20대 중반입니다데 실제
현업에서 저도 느끼고 있지만 매입하는
연령층이 굉장히 좀 낮아졌습니다 2
30대 비율이 좀 높아진 부분이 좀
있는 거 같아요 근데 반대로 매각
하시는 분들은 대체적으로 다 연령이
높았습니다 그래서 기본 다 이제
50대 이상 분들이 많았고 대부분 다
이제 연세가 많으셔 가지고 매각하는
비율이 좀 많이 있었습니다 근데이
중에 한 2 30% 정도는 대출
이자를 감당하지 못해서 매입했던 거
금액보다 더 좀 저렴하게 급매로
매각하는 계약도 좀 있었고요서 정리를
해보면 작년 상반 보다 거래량이
늘어난 건 맞고 그리고 이제 강남구
사람들이 주요 지역으로 좀 많이 찾는
지역 위주로 계약이 많이 됐습니다
그리고 이제 좀 매입하는 연령층이 좀
되게 많이 낮아지고 있고 그리고 이제
매각하는 분들 중에서는 연세가 많으셔
가지고 매각하는 경우가 많지만 그
와중에 이제 좀 급매로 매각된 그런
사례들도 꽤 있었던 거 같습니다 아마
지금 우리 회사 사례처럼 아마 다
비슷할 거 같아요 작년보다는 계약이
좀 더 많아졌고 지역에 거래가 많고
그래서 어 좀이 부분을 참고하셨다가
빌딩 투자하는데 좀 도움이 되셨으면
좋겠고 그리고 예상컨데 하반기 전망도
살짝 하자면 연준에서 금리를 이제 뭐
한 번 내리냐 두 번 내리냐 얘기가
좀 많긴 한데 막상 이제 내리고 나서
당장 거래량이 막 폭발적으로 늘어날
것 같진 않아요 최소 제가 봤을 때는
그래도 한 몇 개월 뒤에 이제
거래량이 좀 더 상승하지 않을까
이렇게 예상을 하고 그리고 지금 주택
가격이 계속 좀 피크를 찍고 있어요
최고가 경신하고 하고 있고 좋은
지역에 있는 주택 같은 경우에 근데
그분들이 나중에 이제 주택을 팔거나
할 때이 돈 가지고 이제 빌딩
시장으로 좀 많이 넘어 오거든요 근데
그 시기가 한 몇 개월 정도
걸리더라고요 그래서 그때 한참 코로나
피크 때도 주택 시장이 오르고 나서
빌딩 시장이 이제 그 뒤로 좀
올랐거든요 그래서 실제로 저희가 이제
강의를 하다 보면 그때 당시에는 거의
6 70% 다 주택
투자자였다 아직까지 주택에 대한
규제가 워낙 많았어 가지고 그런 주택
투자자분들이 빌딩 사로 많이 막
습니다 그때 당시에 뭐 대출도 안
나왔었고 물론 이제 지금 주택 규제가
좀 풀리긴 했지만 부동산을 계속 한번
사셨던 분들은 계속 사거든요 빌딩
같은 경우에도 사실 대출 받아서 주택
매각한 돈으로도 충분히 매입할 수
있기 때문에 그런 투자자분들도 시장이
좀 많이 나올 거 같고 그리고 또
이제 주식 시장도 지금 괜찮긴
하잖아요 그리고 요즘에 해외 주식
많이
사시더라도 버신 분들도 부동산 시장
좀 많이 오지 않을까 이렇게 생각을
합니다 그리고 뭐 코인 시장이 지금
좋지 않지만 그래도 연 는 또
좋아진다는 의견이 좀 많긴 하잖아요
만약에 이제 뭐 코인 가격이 또
오르거나 하면은 빌딩 시장에 넘어오지
않을까 이게 다 약간 맞물려 있어요
필딩 뭐 주식 그다음 주택 다 맞물려
있어요 자산 시장이 아마 이거 가격이
상승하면 같이 덩달아서 오를 거 같고
예상 컨데 하반기에도 작년 하반기보다
거래량이 늘어날 거 같고 그리고
거래량이 좀 상승하는 거는 당장은 좀
폭발하기 어렵지만 조심스럽게
예상하지만 한 내년 한 상반기
쯤부터는 거래 거래량이 되게 많이 더
상승할 것 같습니다 그렇다고 지금
거래량 보신 것처럼 주요 지역에
거래량이 좀 많이 몰려 있기 때문에
만약에 지금 매입하다 하면은 제가
항상 말씀드린 좋은 지역 위주로 좀
투자하시는 걸 좀 권하고 애매한데
사실 거면 진짜 안 사는게 맞습니다
안 팔릴 수도 있어요 빌딩의 가장 큰
문제점이 환금성이 든요 언제든지
시장에 내놨을 때 안 팔릴 수도
있거든요 지금 만약에 내가 뭐 올해
하반기나 아니면 내년에 투자 계획이
있다라고 하시면 좀 잘 팔리는 지역
위주로 괜찮은게 나오면은 투자를
하시면 좋을 것 같습니다 그리고
요즘에 임대 시장이 매우 안 좋아요
오피스 같은 경우에 더 안 좋고
옥석가리기를 잘 하셔야 될 거
같습니다네 아무튼 좀 얘기가
길어졌는데 여러분들 빌딩 투자하는데
있어서 뭐 제가 오늘 말씀드린
데이터가 되게 도움이 많이 되실 것
같아요 그래서 참고해서 좀 성공적인
빌딩 투자 하셨으면 좋겠습니다 오늘
영상 여기까지 하겠습니다
[음악]
감사합니다 y